guten tag meine damen und herren ich
begrüße herzlich in der
bundespressekonferenz den verein der
organisation der berliner parlaments
journalistinnen und journalisten wir
haben heute auch an diesem freitag
wieder den bundesgesundheitsminister zu
gast zur aktuellen lage und an seiner
seite sind der präsident des robert koch
instituts hält professor wille und wir
freuen uns dass zum ersten mal in der
bundespressekonferenz zu gast ist der
staatsminister für gesundheit und pflege
klaus holetschek schön dass er aus
münchen zu uns gekommen sind herzlich
willkommen
wir haben wir uns vorgenommen eine
stunde uns zeit zu nehmen auch aus
infektion logischen gründen
und da es jetzt absehbar schon wieder
viele fragen gibt sowohl aus dem raum
als auch von außen sind schon viele
angemeldet leichter hinweis stellen sie
kurze fragen eine nachfrage zum durch
die frage aufgeworfen thema das sind die
spielregeln die wir haben
wir beginnen einführen mit dem minister
hahn villa und minister holetschek bitte
herr minister sparen lieber herr de
thier meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren das virus gibt nicht einfach auf
das sehen wie dieser tage sehr klar
einerseits sehen wir zuletzt in den wenn
man die letzten zwei drei wochen nehmen
sinkende fallzahlen und eine stetig
steigende zahl an impfung und
gleichzeitig die andere nachricht auch
dieser woche einen steigenden anteil von
besorgniserregenden virus mutationen
auch hier bei uns in deutschland und
tatsächlich beim sinken der zahlen
gerade auch eher eine seitwärtsbewegung
das mahnt zur vorsicht
das bedürfnis nach einem ende des job
booms ist spürbar es ist geradezu
greifbar
aber wir müssen beim öffnen sehr
behutsam und umsichtig vorgehen um auch
das erreichte nicht zu verspielen
die analysen des robert koch instituts
zeigen gerade die im vereinigten
königreich zuerst entdeckte virus
variante ist in deutschland inzwischen
weit verbreitet etwa jeder fünfte
positiv getestete ist mit dieser virus
variante infiziert umso mehr ist es
richtig dass bund und länder in den
besonders betroffenen region
maßnahmen ergreifen und ergriffen haben
dazu gehört es die einreise zu
reglementieren und grenzkontrollen
einzuführen
über die situation in den grenzregionen
sprechen mein kollege holetschek und ich
gleich im anschluss auch zusammen mit
der bundeskanzlerin und dem
ministerpräsident markus söder mit den
landräten und oberbürgermeistern des
freistaates bayern gerade die gute
zusammenarbeit von kommunen und
landkreisen mit bund und ländern hat
sich in dieser pandemie bewährt und ich
darf auch stellvertretend sagen der
klaus holetschek ist gerade auch
vorsitzender der
gesundheitsministerinnen und minister
der bundesländer in diesem jahr
ich darf stellvertretend eben eben auch
danken für die gute zusammenarbeit
zwischen bund und ländern in dieser
pandemie seit nunmehr auch über zwölf
monaten
wir sind öfter mal diesen satz unter
stress vertrauen er gebraucht was
wichtig ist in dieser pandemie und das
tun wir alle in sehr herausfordernden
situationen im bund und ländern in den
letzten monaten und das ist mit ein
anteil auch wenn es manchmal was zu
diskutieren gibt aber bitte führen ja
auch die diskussion stellvertretend
sozusagen oder abbildend die es in der
gesellschaft gibt natürlich auch
zwischen bund und ländern dass wir am
ende dann wenn wir gemeinsam agieren
auch stärker sind bund und länder
agieren gemeinsam auch beim thema
impfungen und deswegen gehören zu dieser
komplexen lage in der wir sind auch die
guten nachrichten
die impfkampagne wird immer schneller es
gibt immer mehr impfungen und auch mehr
verfügbare impfdosen wir haben drei
sichere und wirksame impfstoffe die
zugelassen sind in der europäischen
union mit johnson & johnson steht ein
vierter sozusagen vor der zulassung und
vor der tür und das gerade einmal ein
jahr nach beginn der pandemie
inzwischen sind in deutschland fast fünf
millionen impfdosen verabreicht worden
davon über drei millionen erstimpfung
und auch ein sehr hoher anteil an
zweitimpfung und übrigens bei den
internationalen vergleichen es zu sehen
dass mit über 2 prozent zweikämpfe zwei
prozent der bevölkerung die in vollen
schutz hat mit der zweite impfung wir
durchaus weit vorne liegen wir haben
eben die strategie gerade bei den
besonders schutzbedürftigen
über 80-jährigen denjenigen gegenden
pflegeheim leben oder auch arbeiten
tatsächlich den vollen schutz im
vorgesehenen im abstand zwischen erster
und zweiter empfangen auch zu erreichen
auch die von der europäischen union über
die verträge bereitgestellten impfdosen
die zahl der lieferung steigt stetig bis
ende nächster woche werden 15 bis ende
nächster woche wenn zehn millionen dosen
ausgeliefert sein an deutschland an die
bundesländer wenn wir jetzt knapp fünf
millionen verkaufte dosen haben bis ende
nächster woche insgesamt 10 millionen
gelieferte zeigt sich dass dort deutlich
mehr geschwindigkeit
rein kommt deswegen müssen wir auch klar
vorbereitet sein darauf dass der
impfstoff wenn er da ist auch möglichst
schnell verkauft wird und daran arbeiten
wir mit den ländern intensiv ich will
aber auch sagen wir haben im moment 140
150000 impfungen erst und zwei cent am
tag als höchst zahlen gehabt auch in den
letzten tagen wir werden das in den
nächsten wenigen wochen verdoppeln
müssen mindestens im ersten schritt in
den ländern und in den kapazitäten um
tatsächlich die impfdosen die da sind
auch für impfen zu können und das ist
eben der nächste wichtige schritt danach
und übrigens wenn ich das heute mehrfach
lars bevor sich das festsetzt seitens
des bundesministeriums für gesundheit an
wie nie den ersten april gesetzt zum
start in den arztpraxen ich bitte ich
will jetzt einfach mal ausdrücklich
sagen damit sich nicht wieder ein datum
festsetzt und anschließend fragen alle
warum ist das jetzt nicht passiert wir
haben gesagt wir werden einen zeitpunkt
mit den ländern und den ärzten finden
dann wenn ausreichend impfdosen da sind
dass es auch sinn macht
in den arztpraxen zusätzlich zu impfen
wir bereiten alles vor von der
abrechnungs ziffer bis zur logistik
aber ich kann jetzt noch nicht ein fixes
datum nennen und das sollte sich jetzt
auch nicht festsetzen damit nicht
falsche erwartungen entstehen ein thema
kurz noch zu den test zu werden kommende
woche im corona kabinett die erweiterung
der test strategie beraten
schnelltests sind und das ist der
wichtige unterschied denn gelegentlich
natürlich auch gefragt wird warum nicht
schon im herbst im herbst hatten wir
noch nicht ausreichend
schnellte es zur verfügung für einen
solchen schritt schnell das sind jetzt
ausreichend zur verfügung wir haben
begonnen mit den pflegeeinrichtungen mit
dem gesundheitswesen schulen kitas und
jetzt ist eben auf unter höheren
verfügbarkeit der nächste schritt
möglich deswegen im unser vorschlag sie
ab märz kostenlos für die bürgerinnen
und bürger ein schnelltest möglich zu
machen
und ja das will ich auch jetzt schon
sagen wie immer wenn etwas als
kostenloses angebot für alle startet
wird es am anfang wahrscheinlich auch
schlangen geben
lokal mal engpässe geben können wir uns
alle gemeinsam schon darauf vorbereiten
das ist erst mal ein gutes zeichen denn
es zeigt er dass das angebot angenommen
wird
aber immer dann wenn wir etwas beginnen
ob es die verteilung von schutzmasken
ist ob es das bereitstellen der
grippeschutzimpfung ist ob es eben jetzt
die frage der tests ist es ist am anfang
wenn die nachfrage besonders hoch ist an
ein zwei tagen zu beginn daneben auch
knapp und wir wollen leyen selbsttests
schnellstmöglich zugänglich machen es
wird anfang märz nach jetzigen stand
spätestens anfang märz zulassung geben
durch das pv nach prüfung der unterlagen
das ist mir wichtig wir prüfen die
herstellerangaben und ich bitte einfach
dass wir gemeinsam das wichtig
unterscheiden schnelltests geschultes
personal nicht für jeden kauf bar in den
testzentren selbsttests wird es am ende
überall geben können nicht nur in
apotheken nach der rechtslage können
einzelhandel discounter die wird sehr
breit geben können in der entwicklung am
anfang werden auch die knapp seien die
ersten tests werden zugelassen aber das
wird der entwicklung innerhalb von
wenigen wochen sein wo dieses angebot
dann tatsächlich auch immer weiter
steigt und deswegen können eben diese
schnell und die selbst fest
zwei verschiedene dinge schnell test das
angebot das wir auch kostenlos im märz
machen wollen und dann im nächsten
schritt und zusätzlich die selbsttests
helfen diesen weg raus aus dem block
bauern denen wir mit viel vorsicht und
umsicht gehen wollen zu ebnen sie helfen
uns besser mit dem virus leben zu lernen
und vor allem besser
das virus und die pandemie zu
kontrollieren herr minister mit herrn
gemeinsam haben wir in den letzten
wochen wirklich sehr viel erreicht in
einigen bundesländern ist die sieben
tages inzidenz unter 50 pro 100000
einwohner auch schon gefallen aber wir
stehen möglicherweise erneut an einem
wendepunkt der rückläufige trend der
letzten wochen setzt sich offenbar nicht
mehr frau im bundesweiten fallzahlen
scheint zu stagnieren und auch die
bundes heute sieben tage since i denn es
geht nicht mehr so stark zurück ja in
einem bundesland in thüringen momentan
steigt sie sogar
es sieht im moment so aus als steuerten
viele bundesländer auf ein plateau zu
aber dieses plateau ist immer noch zu
hoch und leider werden dem robert koch
sie doch nach wie vor mehrere hundert
todesfälle pro tag ermittelt und die
frage ist warum ist das so warum
bekommen wir das infektionsgeschehen
nicht besser in den griff obwohl wir
doch genau wissen wie wir uns schützen
können wissen doch das wir uns
hauptsächlich in innenräumen anstecken
wenn sich zu viele menschen dort
aufhalten wird zu eng zusammen sind also
wir müssen abstand halten oder wenn wir
uns zu lange dort aufhalten wenn sie
nicht genug lüften oder keine masken
tragen
das wissen wir doch alles spielen hier
eventuell die besorgniserregenden
varianten schon eine rolle
meine damen und herren das wissen wir
noch nicht genau
aber was wir wissen ist dass sich die
variante b 11 7 in deutschland
ausbreitet dass ihr anteil an allen saß
kopf zwei infektionen wirklich rasant
steigt wie 117 ist noch ansteckender das
wissen wir auch seit einigen wochen und
wahrscheinlich auch noch gefährlicher
wir müssen uns aber darauf einstellen
dass die bekämpfung der pandemie dadurch
auch schwieriger wird unser ziel ist es
ja nach wie vor die infektionszahlen
herunterzubringen und dauerhaft auf
einem niedrigen niveau zu halten wenn
sich bei 117 weiter ausbreitet dann wird
es schwieriger dieses ziel zu erreichen
es wird schwieriger weil sie innerhalb
kurzer zeit noch mehr menschen anstecken
als sonst und wahrscheinlich noch mehr
menschen auch dann schwer erkranken
trotzdem können müssen wir es schaffen
dass wir sind
halt meine damen und herren denn die
maßnahmen wie wirken ja auch gegen die
neuen virus varianten
das zeigt die erfahrung in anderen
ländern auch deshalb ist es so wichtig
dass sie weiter konsequent umgesetzt
werden diese maßnahmen die wir alle
inzwischen sehr gut kennen also brauchen
wir uns hier nicht entmutigen zu lassen
lassen wir uns weiter ansteckungen
verhindern
für alle haben das zum großen teil
wirklich selber in unseren händen
meine bitte schenken wir weiterhin
unsere kontakte auf das allernötigste
ein treffen wir möglichst wenige und
wenn dann nur dieselben menschen und
wenn sie und wie geht treffen wir sie
draußen halten wir uns immer an die a h
und l regeln und auch wenn wir den
anderen gut kennen oder die andere wir
können natürlich selber auch schon
ansteckend sein bevor wir symptome haben
das ist ja einer dieser herausforderung
mit dem virus das dürfen wir bitte immer
nicht vergessen und wenn es eng wird in
räumen dann bitte tage wie immer masken
und begrenzten natürlich den aufenthalt
auf das notwendigste und die masten
bitte über mund und nase tragen auch im
büro auch im auto oder im lkw mit
kollegen maske tragen und natürlich auch
in allen öffentlichen verkehrsmittel
bleiben wir alles schon bei den ersten
anzeichen einer atemwegsinfektion auch
zu hause und rufen wir dann in einer
arztpraxis an und testen zu lassen die
kapazitäten für tests sind da aufgrund
der geringen inzidenz sind natürlich
viele kapazitäten frei die können wir
großzügig nutzen und wenn einer von uns
positiv getestet wurde
dann lasst uns bitte alle umgehend die
menschen um uns herum informieren
darüber
damit sie sich selber schützen können
und wenn es irgendwie möglich ist
sollten wir moment auch nicht verreisen
wir müssen ja nicht unbedingt viren aus
unserem land in andere länder schleppen
oder aus anderen ländern in unser land
schleppen
und wenn wir eine impfung angeboten
bekommen dann sollten wir uns freuen und
uns einfach impfen lassen alle
impfstoffe die in deutschland zur
verfügung stehen sind sicher und sind
wirksam und alle schützen
vor einer kurve 19 erkrankungen und nach
allem was wir wissen schützen sie auch
vorerkrankungen mit den neuen varianten
des virus meine damen und herren hat
einen boost erhalten ja und es macht
große sprünge und da dürfen wir nicht
rückwärtsgehen jede unbedachte lockerung
beschleunigt das virus und wirft uns
zurück dann stehen wir in ein paar
wochen wieder genau an dem punkt wo wir
weihnachten waren da und haben mir geht
es wirklich um folgendes weil sich die
ansteckenden virus varianten bei uns
ausbreiten erwarte ich in den kommenden
wochen mehr ausbrüche auch unter
jüngeren menschen es werden auch mehr
junge erwachsene jugendliche und auch
kinder erkranken
unser verhalten das wir uns alle an die
maßnahmen halten das ist das wichtigste
und mächtigste mittel das wir selber in
der hand haben um uns alle schützen zu
können und selber und uns gegenseitig
alte menschen kinder und alle dazwischen
und wir können uns schützen gemeinsam
können wir uns vorwärts darauf
vorbereiten dass wie auf eine schönere
zeit zu steuern aber jeder von uns muss
das steuer eben auch selbst in die hand
nehmen die entscheidungsträger müssen
sie ihrer verantwortung stellen und
zusätzlich muss jeder einzelne mit
steuern je mehr leute in die gleiche
richtung fahren und steuern desto
schneller drängen wir dieses virus
zurück und desto mehr menschen schützen
wir auch auf dem weg in einer wirklich
bessere und schönere zahlen jedes mal
wenn wir das virus aktiv bremsen dann
kommen wir einen schritt weiter und
herzlichen dank ich will vielleicht auch
noch mal einleiten sagen das thema
perspektive mit umsicht und vorsicht ist
die überschrift und das merken wir in
bayern glaube ich auch speziell an zwei
punkten einmal haben wir einen incidents
wert heute von 54 7 ging also im
vergleich der länder auf platz elf unter
dem bundesdurchschnitt aber wir merken
natürlich auch die auswirkungen der
grenze und wenn man jetzt nach wunsiedel
tirschenreuth hoch schaut dann sind wir
dort über 300 bzw zwei perspektiven
schaffen aber tatsächlich vorsichtig und
umsichtig zu bleiben das ist die
botschaft glaube ich wie wichtig ist und
deswegen begleiten wir auch die grenz
landkreise sehr eng mit verschiedenen
maßnahmen mit testungen
mit dem thema penta quarantäne und ich
glaube auch dass die grenzkontrolle
tatsächlich ein wichtiges instrument im
moment ist so schwierig sie ist aber im
moment glaube ich hilft sie uns einfach
um die festungen zu kontrollieren und um
auch zu schauen dass der virus sich
nicht weiter verbreitet das thema der
impfungen ist glaube ich ein ist es uns
alle beschäftigt und und länder
gemeinsam
es ist ja klar wie die rollen dort
verteilt sind und ich glaube wir
bereiten uns im moment darauf vor die
kapazitäten deutlich hochzufahren
das ist ein wichtiges thema weil wir
alle eine verantwortung haben und die
wollen wir so leben dass wir sagen der
impfstoff der da ist muss möglichst
schnell auch fest werden das ist das
ziel
wir haben in bayern über 100 impfzentren
gibt es können die im moment
ausgerichtet sind auf eine
tageskapazität von 46.000 menschen und
ich glaube das ist auch richtig und
wichtig ist die arztpraxen mit
einzubeziehen wenn der impfstoff da ist
das halte ich für absolut notwendig ist
zudem betriebsärzten also ich denke das
muss einfach ein prozess sein den wir an
steuern
wir tun das im moment in bayern in
verschiedenen pilotprojekten nicht in
der regelversorgung aber wir versuchen
die arztpraxen jetzt schon anzudocken
auch an die impfzentren und eben
loszulegen weil wir da möglichst schnell
dann auch in die regelversorgung
einsteigen wollen und ich glaube das ist
ein ganz zentrales thema impfen ist uns
ins ist ein stückweit licht am ende des
tunnels deswegen müssen wir alles tun
mit den impfstoffen die wir haben auch
da raus zu gehen ich bin ganz froh dass
sich viele jetzt äußern auch zu
astrazeneca positiv dass viele
wissenschaftler und ärzte herausgehen
in meiner wahrnehmung bei den
bürgerinnen und bürger nämlich
verschiedenes war ich sagt es auch ganz
offen es gibt die einen die sagen dann
lasst euch politiker doch als erstes
impfen
und es gibt die anderen die sagen ich
würde mich sofort impfen lassen
deswegen glaube ich ist es gut dass wir
auch da wirklich vernünftig bleiben dass
wir sagen sein impfstoff der wirbt und
der hilft und jetzt heute gibt es ja
auch eine neue umfrage dass die mehrheit
der deutschen sagt lehrerinnen und
lehrer und kindergärten und kindergärten
sollen glaube ich vorrangig geimpft
werden entgegen der stiko jens wir
werden uns daher in der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz montag war
ich auch darüber unterhalten
ich denke man muss das wirklich so
machen dass man da auch über die
priorisierungen
nach denkt in diesen bereichen und auch
dann entscheidungen fällt gerade auch im
hinblick auf die impfstoffe die jetzt
noch knapp sind und die zur verfügung
stehen
das thema schnelltests begrüße ich
ausdrücklich ich glaube das thema
testung hilft uns das ist ein wichtiger
teil einer gesamtstrategie
wir müssen natürlich die umsetzung und
die konkreten voraussetzungen auch
kennen und wissen aber da werden wir uns
ja auch nochmal heute insgesamt darüber
unterhalten und ich denke auch den ein
oder anderen weg finden wie wird es
gemeinsam nach vorne bringen ein letzter
punkt noch ganz kurz der mir wirklich am
herzen liegt er nicht jetzt die pandemie
oder cohen hat ganz unmittelbar betrifft
ist das thema pflege und da weiß ich
dass der bundesminister ähnlich denkt
wie ich ich glaube wir brauchen jetzt in
zukunft mutig und große schritte um die
pflege zu unterstützen und pflegekräften
zu helfen von steuererleichterungen über
die frage des rentensystems ich glaube
wir müssen groß denken wir müssen
außerhalb der bestehenden wege denken
und wir müssen neu denken die pflege
wird eine schicksalsfrage der
generationen werden und die pflegekräfte
brauchen zwar auch einen bonus aber ich
glaube jetzt brauchen viel mehr
nachhaltige und deutliche
unterstützungen für ihre
arbeitsbedingungen und auch für die
zukunft vielen dank an minister so dann
fangen wir an mit den fragen die ersten
sind henkel frau aus bad hersfeld eine
frage an minister sparen es gibt ein
berichtender seinen sonderbeauftragten
für die impfstoffproduktion geben soll
können sie das bestätigen und ist das
eigentlich ein zeichen dafür dass die
ministerien bisher ihre arbeit nicht
gemacht haben also zuerst einmal zum
einordnen gibt ja sozusagen verschiedene
themen bei dem thema impfstoffe das eine
ist die versorgung sicherzustellen das
was wir gerade zwischen bund und ländern
bei den gesundheitsminister natürlich im
fokus haben wie kriegen wir den
impfstoff für deutschland für die bürger
und vor allem wie wird er dann färbt das
ist klassisch aufgabe trägers der
gesundheitspolitik und der ministerien
für gesundheit wir hatten vorher das
thema forschungsförderung unterstützung
klassisch aufgabe des
forschungsministeriums wo wir als
bundesregierung auch mit 750 millionen
euro
zum beispiel ein förderprogramm
aber auch andere und das andere thema
ist aufbau von produktionskapazitäten
beziehungsweise auch zuschauen auch in
der lieferkette lipide ist ja ein
begriff denn jetzt auch viele
mittlerweile oder das produkt diese
lösen oder wie immer man es nennen will
jedenfalls die helfen dass der impfstoff
tatsächlich auch dann ankommt wo
ankommen soll also die versorgungsketten
bei der produktion das ist eben klasse
schon seit mai mit einem produktions
starb auch im bundesministerium für
wirtschaft angesiedelt und wir haben
jetzt auch im gespräch mit den
herstellern die wir alle führen aufgrund
der unterschiedlichen themen
festgestellt dass es nicht wenige
hersteller gibt sowohl schon in
deutschland befindliche wie
internationale die darüber nachdenken in
deutschland zu investieren und das ist
übrigens eine perspektive die mir sehr
wichtig ist auch über die pandemie
hinaus wir haben jetzt die chance den
standort den pharmastandort deutschland
für die 20er jahre wirklich zu stärken
und einer der impfstoffherstellung
städten der welt zu werden gerade bei
den modernen impfstoffe und deswegen
braucht es eben ein förderprogramm und
so ein förderprogramm auch geld brauchen
sie das finanzministerium so ein
förderprogramm braucht vor allem leute
die sich sehr gut auskennen mit
vergaberecht weil natürlich wenn sie
fördern produktion in deutschland sehr
schnell sich europarechtliche
vergaberechtliche fragen stellen vor
allem in schnell gehen soll
es darf jetzt nicht zwölf monate oder
sechs monate dauern ich finde wir müssen
das sagen auch die hersteller diese
entscheidung jetzt zügig treffen und
daraus hat sich eben ergeben dass wir
seitens der bundesregierung sagen wir
führen das noch mal zusammen
herr krupp wird das tatsächlich kann ich
bestätigen
für uns als regierung als corona
kabinett koordinieren und zu arbeiten im
bundesministerium für wirtschaft
angesiedelt und vor allem dieses thema
kurzfristig ja bei den lieferketten aber
vor allem auch mittelfristig wie kriegen
wir mehr investitionen für und in
deutschland in die impfstoffproduktion
und wirklich für die 20er jahre aus
deutschland ein impfstoff
produktionshalle zu machen das eben zu
bündeln und das macht unbedingt sinn wir
bringen sozusagen ein die expertise
welche art macht sinn welche bedarfe
sind da auch im sinne von pandemic
preparedness vorbereitung auf pandemien
man kann zum beispiel zu reden aber
damit er ihnen doch kurz man kann zum
beispiel
man kann zum beispiel gut fördern oder
reservieren das ist teil dieses plans
produktionskapazität in schöne nächste
pandemie
das sind also sozusagen über kapazitäten
für den normalbetrieb aber eben
kapazitäten die man jetzt schon
reserviert damit man in den nächsten
pandemie sofort auch in höherer volumen
produzieren kann das kostet dann geld
reservierungs gebühren solche konzepte
einfach zu erarbeiten mit der industrie
das unter anderem soll dort geschehen
und ich finde es gut dass wir das jetzt
eben miteinander bündeln
das ist die frage die es auch von
mehreren kollegen von außen aufgerufen
worden von frau ellermann von herrn
jordaans und von anno fricke allenfalls
noch die ergänzung von denen noch mal
konkret war und wie genau war das
bundesministerium in die schaffung
dieser stelle eingebunden
wir haben ja zwischen finanzminister
wirtschaftsminister eine frau
bundeskanzlerin und ich verschiedene
welche in den letzten
das haben wir jetzt überhaupt mitte
februar sechs wochen über diese frage
der impfstoffproduktion geredet und ich
hab immer wieder das thema aufgebracht
andere auch dass uns eben die
produzenten ansprechen und sagen sie
würden gerne in deutschland investieren
sie würden in anderen ländern auch
bestimmte bedingungen dafür angeboten
bekommen sie kennen die themen
investitionszuschüsse oder sie würden in
über kapazitäten investieren wenn wir
eben etwa solche reservierungen
vornehmen
wer denn der richtige ansprechpartner
dafür wäre das haben wir zwei drei mal
erhöht hat in der runde
weil das gar nicht so leicht ist er
dafür der richtige ansprechpartner ist
ich habe gerade gesagt das sind
verschiedene ministerien zuständig und
um das am ende wirklich zu strukturieren
haben wir eben gemeinsam in corona
kabinett und in diesem in dieser
arbeitsgruppe für die produktion
überlegt über das am besten auf setzen
dass es sinn macht dafür jetzt eben
einen ansprechpartner zu haben weil alle
unsere ministerien sind ja im
tagesgeschäft wenn sie mich jetzt fragen
würden hätten sie jemand im haus der das
sozusagen
weil eben auch noch machen kann dann
wird das nicht gehen und so geht es den
kollegen in finanz- und
wirtschaftsministerium auch die sind
alle voll eingespannt
deswegen haben wir entschieden vor ein
zwei wochen in einem gespräch eben dass
wir eine solche struktur mit herrn
gruppe aufbauen um einfach sehr wichtig
für die hersteller in die treffen
millionen investitionsentscheidungen die
brauchen ansprechpartner der verlässlich
ja auch da ist und dann haben wir das
miteinander entschieden
herr krug wurde gefragt er hat dafür bin
ich dankbar darüber freue ich mich er
hat viel erfahrung gerade um die bei den
themen um die es geht ja gesagt und dann
wird das jetzt beginnt der debatte
welche grenzwert geht denn jetzt im
infektionsschutzgesetz haben zwar beide
werte auf 35 und 50
aber schon damals gab es kritik dass
nicht bp wird festgehalten wird was man
wirklich was passiert und genau diese
debatte tritt jetzt ein rechtlich dass
das wirklich genau festgelegt worden ist
als unterlegen markenamt verschiedene
abstufungen zu verstehen
wissen sie die eigentliche
herausforderung ist ja nicht sogar noch
mal öffentlich zu sagen darf ein stück
vorher das thema ist ja dass die
grenzwerte 50 und 35 im
infektionsschutzgesetz sozusagen
eigentlich grenzwerte ja für die andere
richtung sind also dass ich wenn ich
über 35 komme bestimmte maßnahmen
ergriffen werden sollen und rechtlich
möglich sind und wenn ich über 50 komme
noch verstärkte zusätzliche maßnahmen
und deswegen ist glaube ich auch dieses
diese debatte entstanden so dass das
gefühl wenn wir über 55 sind dann kann
es schnell raus gehen aus dem lockt dann
aber es bringt ja nichts wenn wir bei 47
sind und dann die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass wir fünf tage später wieder über 50
sind dann sehr hoch ist und wir dann in
so einem hin und her sind und deswegen
ist eben auch diese 35er incidents immer
mitgedacht wir haben immer gesagt gerade
die erfahrungen der letzten zwölf monate
aus vielen ausbrüchen und entwicklung
ist wenn sie einmal so über 35
durchschießen dann ist es echt schwer
überhaupt die entwicklung wenn sie
einmal über 50 sind sowieso nur
aufzuhalten dass man also eben
rechtzeitig beginnen muss
mit maßnahmen und das muss jetzt eben
umgekehrt in der cascade sozusagen
runter dann auch definiert werden und
deswegen finde ich es gut dass es
zwischen bund und ländern ja auch die
vereinbarung gibt in einer arbeitsgruppe
diesen stufen plan wie es genannt wir
durch diese abstufung dieser abfolge zu
diskutieren die natürlich einfach
abhängen von der entwicklung der
professor wähler hat es ja gerade gesagt
das ist im moment schwierig mit dem
anteil der mutation der wächst und der
vermutung der evidenzbasierten vermutung
dass diese frist war ich schon selbst
britische war die die variante die
zuerst in großbritannien entdeckt worden
ist dass die tatsächlich
ansteckungsfähigkeit ist dass das was
bedeutet für das infektionsgeschehen das
ist im moment das sozusagen für uns
schwierige politisch aber auch für uns
als gesellschaft und für jeden einzelnen
in dem erwartungsmanagement die zahlen
sind gesunken
sie sinken auch heute wenn auch deutlich
weniger stark und gleichzeitig sehen wir
dass die riskantere variante sich
ausbreitet und daraus jetzt wenn wir
sagen wir wollen vorsichtig diesen weg
gehen die konkreten richtigen
schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen
das wird jetzt unsere aufgabe sein das
bis zum dritten märz zu besprechen
sie haben sozusagen relevant im
landkreis oder im wunderbar ergänzen
noch die fragen von außen die dazu
passen mit rein von sascha meyer dpa von
gernot heller herrn jordaans ob diese 35
die frage auch explizit am herrn wieder
formuliert und an minister holetschek ob
das als flächen als flächen der wert
realistisch ist mit blick auf geplante
öffnungen insbesondere öffnungen von
schulen also kurz nur zum einzelnen
beschluss der letzten des gesprächs der
bundesregierung mit dem
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der sogenannten mpk
dort ist ja bewusst eben nicht bundes
oder landes weit formuliert worden
sondern eben der blick das ist ja auch
in der diskussion anschließend deutlich
geworden auch auf regionaler ebene
glücklich und das ist ja die situation
die wir seit zwölf monaten auch in
unserer strategie sozusagen beschreiben
dass dann wenn in einer region und schon
der unterschied in bayern ist ja gerade
beschrieben worden wie weit sozusagen
die inzidenz unterschiede sind wenn in
einer region im viel höhere instanzen
die viel höhere infektionsgeschehen viel
mehr dynamik ist eine in einer anderen
das dann auch wir wieder dahin kommen
jetzt schrittweise nachdem es im herbst
notwendig war bundeseinheitlich zu
agieren dass es auch differenziertes
vorgeben geben kann wir haben landkreise
die liegen unter 10
und wir haben dann kreise siegen über
200 und man wird jetzt noch eine
zeitlang im gemeinsamen geleitzug er
sein aber natürlich 40 denkt in der
debatte jetzt das auch immer weiter
ausdifferenzieren und aus meiner sicht
für die akzeptanz auch aus
differenzieren müssen aber auch da muss
man sein regionalclub machen wenn der
eine landkreis im block dornis und der
andere einer geringen inzidenz und alle
fahren da drüben einkaufen das ist nicht
sinn der sache
deswegen müssen wir alle miteinander
auch dann regional die dinge klug
abgestimmt machen ich kann das nur sagen
natürlich sind diese zahlen realisierbar
aber diese pandemie wurde doch vom
ersten tag an dem lokal bekommt
ich meine diese gesundheitsämter
arbeiten lokal die ärzte arbeiten lokal
die patienten leben in ihrem wohnort
also die bekämpfung war immer lokal und
wird es natürlich auch bleiben und man
kann diese zahl von 35 erreichen sie
sehen doch dass es jetzt schon
landkreise in unserem land gibt die das
erreicht hat
naja ich kann das eigentlich auch nur
unterstreichen ich denke wir brauchen
kluge lösungen die natürlich sich
orientieren an den werten die aber auch
natürlich mobilität mit einbeziehen in
die fragen andere bezüge zwischen
bundesländern die natürlich auch da sein
können wenn ich jetzt an baden
württemberg und bayern denke dort wo ich
herkomme aus memmingen wo die sehr nahe
zusammen liegt denke ich dann muss man
das einfach gut und klug bewerten wir
haben es ja jetzt bei den schuhen und
auch schon gemacht wo wir an den werten
auch festmachen wie wir jetzt ab montag
dann dort weiter machen und ich denke
das ist jetzt die grosse herausforderung
tatsächlich das stichwort mobilität und
die bezüge die sich in der region dann
ergeben möglicherweise mit
unterschiedlichen werten zusammen zu
führen und das ist ja auch das thema
perspektive mit vorsicht und umsicht zu
schaffen
herr kreutzfeldt dann weil wir in der
reihe das hobby schon so eine frage an
herrn spahn und herren bielern sie haben
beide gesagt die inzidenz zahlen
insgesamt sinken nur noch langsam die
mutations zahlen steigen
trotzdem wollen ja mehrere bundesländer
in der nächsten woche die schule wieder
den chor enz unterricht wieder aufnehmen
oder deutlich ausweiten
auch spitzenreiter länder darunter
halten sie das für verantwortbar in der
derzeitigen situation
die frage ist ja wie unter welchen
bedingungen und mit welchen konzepten
und deswegen ist es ihm wichtig ob es
gibt es ja auch empfehlungen des robert
koch instituts und mittlerweile auch
entwickelt ja auch eine leitlinie zur
frage wie in schulen das richtige
konzept ist um wieder auch zu beginnen
was wechsel unterricht angeht was
abstand räume fragen und anderes angeht
und das ist dann eben wichtig dass das
in diesem gesamten solchen konzepten die
dann auch bis hin ergänzt um test
konzepte die ihr auch alle bundesländer
entwickelt haben und weiter entwickeln
dass das dann geschieht und dass wir
zeit lang man sie müssen sehen dass der
beginn von schule und kita löst in jedem
bundesland bewegungen in also in meinem
bundesland nordrhein westfalen 1
millionen größe aus kleineren
bundesländern relativ jedenfalls immer
groß sind viele viele millionen kinder
jeden tag dann auf dem weg zur schule zu
kita lehrer erzieher eltern die sie
bringen abholen das löst mobilität aus
schule und kita in sehr großem umfang
und deswegen ist es ihm wichtig dann
auch miteinander zu schauen wo stehen
wir da nach einer woche oder zehn tagen
was macht das mit dem
infektionsgeschehen dass da nicht so
sehr wie das alle hätten gerne so ein
automatismus schritt 1 eine woche später
schritt 2
der automatismus geht aber nicht wir
müssen schauen was schritt eins mit sich
bringt
ob wir es weiterhin unter kontrolle
behalten oder ob wir dann lieber mit
schritt 2 warten und die frage wird sich
daneben stellen sie ist für
verantwortbar halten habe ich jetzt noch
nicht ganz verstanden unter den
richtigen bedingungen ist das eine
entscheidung am ende verantworten dass
de dies entscheiden ist das eine
entscheidung die man treffen kann wenn
das infektionsgeschehen entsprechend ist
die konzepte wie lahm liegen vor
die konzepte sind allen bekannt und die
konzepte sind einfach durchzuführen ja
das ist trivial
es hat genug zeit gegeben die konzepte
vorzubereiten und umzusetzen und man
sollte jetzt auch wirklich nur unter
nutzung dieser konzepte öffnen wir haben
rund 8 millionen schüler in deutschland
und schülerinnen knapp 700.000 lehrer
und man sollte dann möglichst wenn man
öffnet erst die jungen jahrgänge kitas
und grundschulen öffnen gewissen
das infektionsgeschehen einzuschätzen
aber es müssen die schutzkonzepte die
vorliegen und bekannt sind umgesetzt
werden das ist die voraussetzung für die
öffnung von grundschulen und kitas dann
aber den körper vom zdf herr minister
sie haben mehrfach ihre test strategie
angepasst das ergebnis ist
offensichtlich dass es so schlecht läuft
dass wir anfang februar im europäischen
vergleich platz 22 von 27 waren ihr
könnte das erklären also zum ersten sind
einfach da müssen wir uns miteinander
dran gewöhnen werden wir immer wieder
dinge anpassen müssen weil sich halt die
lage verändert im august
unser hauptthema wie testen wir
reiserückkehrer und wir bauen werden
flughäfen test kapazitäten auf mit dem
thema flughafen test kapazität löse ich
unser aktuelles problem nicht damals
waren 50 prozent der infektionen aus dem
ausland reingetragen durchreise
rückkehrende heute ist es unter 1
prozent
insofern müssen wir unsere strategie und
auch andere strategien beständig an das
anpassen wie sich die dinge entwickeln
zum zweiten hängt es sehr stark von der
verfügbarkeit ab wir hatten am anfang
und das ist bis heute der goldstandard
die pcr tests in den laboren
wir haben dann schnelltests antigen
schnelltests vor allem möglich gemacht
in der finanzierung zugelassen waren
übrigens viele schon vorher brauchen die
an der europäische zulassung
zertifiziert
aber wir haben sie in die test
verordnung übernommen als wir auch
sicher waren dass sie gut genug sind das
vor allem die die gut genug sind auch
ausreichend verfügbar sind für das
gesundheitswesen pflegeeinrichtungen
krankenhäuser nächster schritt waren
schulen kitas aber immer parallel zur
verfügbarkeit also ich weiß noch wie im
dezember mich ministerpräsidenten
angerufen haben und gesagt haben
wie kriegen für unsere pflegeeinrichtung
nicht genug tests können sie uns helfen
und wir haben zweimal helfen können am
ende in dem wir eben unterstützt dann
bei der beschaffung aber es war im
dezember echt schwierig ausreichend
tests überhaupt für die ersten schritte
zu haben so die situation hat sich jetzt
bis mitte februar so verbessert auch bei
den produktionskapazitäten und der
verfügbarkeit das mittlerweile deutlich
mehr tests angeboten werden als
nachgefragt werden bei den schnelltest
und das gibt uns die möglichkeit den
nächsten schritt zu gehen hätten wären
wir diesen schritt den wir jetzt gehen
wollen
im november gegangen dann wäre nach zwei
tagen spätestens bright and deutschland
dabei ein instrument test verfügbar
wenn überhaupt zwei tage durchgehalten
worden wäre und deswegen geht das eben
nur schritt für schritt nach der
verfügbarkeit europäischer vergleich
wissen sie ich bin sehr für vergleiche
auch immer für für benchmarks und
schauen wo wir besser sind aber da wird
halt häufig auch äpfel und birnen
verglichen
sie müssen genau schauen wo geht es um
pcr tests und pcr test kapazitäten wo
werden die schnelltests mit 1 gezählt
und einberechnet werden auch selbst
selbsttests doch mittlerweile in die
statistik ein geführt und sie können
halt nicht unsere pcr kapazität
vergleichen mit schnelltests in
großbritannien oder in new york oder was
was gelegentlich so passiert und
deswegen bin ich immer sehr fürs genauer
vergleichen aber auch da sehen wir eben
wir können noch mehr testen und das
genau ist ja das was wir im märz auch
vor
mit platz 22 von 27 zufrieden wenn platz
22 ich kenne die statistik nicht das
immer schwierig über statistiken
realitäten
ja ich glaube eher dass es die gibt ich
kenne sie halt nur nicht unter sie muss
man schauen was da verglichen wird
ich bin immer dafür dass wir weit vorne
dabei sind ich bin aber auch immer dafür
dass man den gesamtblick macht
ich finde es ein bisschen passiert im
moment in der debatte in deutschland und
das löst dann ja manchmal auch zu
spiralen aus irgendwie in dieser
schwierigen phase die uns alle nervt
dass wir uns irgendwann so einer
negativspirale reden dann meinen schritt
zurücktreten und schauen wie ist
deutschland wie sind wir als
gesellschaft als nation durch diese
zweite und aus meiner sicht auch dritte
welle gekommen die sich im dezember wäre
ja so und dann ging es los andere länder
hatten so und dann zeitlich versetzt so
wir hatten zwei dritte welle in einem
wenn sie damals zurücktreten und
bisschen drauf schauen im vergleich auch
in europa sind wir nicht schlecht durch
diese schwierige phase gekommen
es ist mit viel leid verbunden mit
vielen herten aber wenn ich schaue wie
es in anderen ländern auch gelaufen ist
keiner stelle eine überlastung des an
keiner stelle eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems ich bin sehr dafür
dass wir alles dafür tun dass wir
bestmöglich durchkommen aber ich finde
immer wichtig dass man die vergleiche
etwas breiter zieht als immer nur auf
eine zahl und eine kennziffer und einen
tag und jeden tag irgendwie sich das
glaube ich führt nicht wirklich weiter
eine ganz kurze ergänzung dazu wir haben
ja schon seit juli 2020 eine nationale
test strategie und da gibt es ein
gremium das sich kontinuierlich damit
befasst und das immer wieder anpasst und
viele dinge die manchmal gefordert
werden auch in der öffentlichkeit stehen
aber da ja schon drin da würde ich auch
einfach drauf bitten dass man diese
unterlagen an schaut also wir haben das
immer angepasst und zwar den infektions
epidemiologischen gegebenheiten und der
verfügbarkeit von tests und das ist ja
das was sie jedoch erwarten von von vom
robert-koch-institut oder gemeinsam mit
dem bundesministerium für gesundheit
dass wir strategisch entsprechend die
testungen
passen das machen wir kontinuierlich und
diese strategie gibt es seit juli 2020
insofern sollte man die auch immer
anschauen und dann muss sie aber eben
auch umgesetzt werden das ist ja dann
der nächste punkt und dann wirkt sie uns
frau und herr sternberg zudem stand der
impfungen im pflegeheim das ziel war ja
bis mitte februar möglichst 1 1 im
pfarrbüro zu machen können sie sagen wie
weit ist man da und wie ist die
impfquote in den pflegeheim und wenn ich
darf eine kurze nachfrage zu dem was er
hologic gesagt hat verstehe ich das
richtig dass am montag eine entscheidung
fallen soll was die improvisieren von
lehrern trifft also zum ersten aber
vielleicht kann der hologic einfach aus
der bayrischen erfahrung was die
pflegeeinrichtungen die bewohnerinnen
und bewohner angeht zum ersten sehen wir
ja wir haben jetzt aus dem kopf sagen
über weit über 700.000 geimpfte in den
pflegeeinrichtungen 740.000
bewohnerinnen und bewohner in den
pflegeeinrichtungen erst geimpft ein
sehr großer teil gott sei dank weil der
vollschutz ist wichtig auch schon mit
der zweite impfung geimpft nämlich fast
500.000 der pflege heimbewohnerinnen und
bewohner und die allermeisten
bundesländer berichten uns dass sie
zumindest bei der angebot der
erstimpfung tatsächlich auch haben alle
pflegeeinrichtungen erreichen können
noch nicht alle alle aber die meisten
dann doch alle haben erreichen können
wir müssen ein zimmer sehen ist neben ja
nicht 100% sozusagen das angebot aus
unterschiedlichen gründen medizinische
gründe geben dass man andere gründe
geben
das angebot an und wenn ich da die
zuschauerzahl der pflegeheimbewohner
zahl der impfungen sind wir sehr gut an
diesem ziel dran
zur frage und priorisieren machen wir
haben wir vereinbart eine werden wir den
vorschlag auch machen wie wir damit
umgehen seitens des bundesministeriums
darüber reden wenn bei der konsens
erzielen zum thema erzieherin erzieher
grundschuljahren grundschullehrer das
dann auch zügig umsetzen
aus unserer sicht kann man das deswegen
auch herleiten und rechtfertigen weil
wir bei kitas und grundschulen vor allem
die kitas systeme abstand und hygiene
also sozusagen nicht so umgesetzt werden
kann wie etwa in der oberstufe und
deswegen waren eben auch diese schulform
oder kita und andere schulformen auch
unterschiedlich durchaus behandeln kann
beim thema impfen
dann will ich das vielleicht kurz
ergänzen
ich befürworte das ausdrücklich übrigens
dass wir lehrerinnen und lehrer und
kindergärten kindergärten mit
einbeziehen in diese frage dass wir auch
eine klare entscheidung fällen wie die
mehrheit der deutschen dass jetzt auch
heute noch mal in der umfrage gesagt hat
wir werden uns da sicherlich auch in
zukunft über weitere themen unterhalten
müssen was die priorisierung angeht oder
auch für die stiko noch weitere
herausforderungen geben glaube ich an
dieser stelle was das thema alten und
pflegeheime angeht bin ich wirklich sehr
froh dass die neuinfektionen deutlich
zurückgegangen sind bei uns in bayern
dass wir durch enges testen durch gute
beratung durch begleitung der
einrichtung und wirklich erreicht haben
dass wir dort auf einem guten weg sind
das gilt auch für die impfungen 99
prozent der altenpflege einrichtungen in
bayern sind besucht worden mit einer
erstimpfung wir haben 78 prozent der
bewohnerinnen und bewohner und glaube
ich mit anmeldungen 52 prozent bei den
pflegekräften was die impfbereitschaft
angeht und die impfungen und ich denke
das ist ein gutes thema was wir beachten
müssen dass die herausforderung sein
dass wir in den pflegeheimen immer
dranbleiben müssen weil wir einen
stetigen wechsel dort haben das heißt
nach einem jahr wären sie schon sehen
dass wieder bewohnerinnen und bewohnern
eugens werden müssen oder vielleicht nur
noch kämpft dann in die einrichtung
kommen
das darf man nicht vergessen dass wird
also eine dauernde herausforderung und
aufgabe bleiben aber wir sind da sehr
froh dass wir da wirklich auf einem
guten weg sind auch was die
neuinfektionen
jetzt habe ich einen verwickelt
entschuldigung ich hab mir machen wird
sich präsent gab sie was ein heimlich
sondern eine frage an entspannend
holetschek jetzt häufen sich die
meldungen zu nicht genutzten dosen des
astra zeneca impfstoff gibt es eine
konkrete perspektive das an jüngere
menschen die nicht in den priorisierten
gruppen sind sich früher impfen lassen
können deswegen darf ich da vielleicht
weil das passt nämlich noch zur
astrazeneca fragen von außen rein die
uns von verschiedenen kolleginnen
kollegen erreichen von rtv slowenien von
reuters vom büro herholz auch die frage
sollte mit blick auf astra zeneca die im
freien folge noch mal geändert werden
frage warum ist so wenig von den
verfügbaren astrazeneca impfstoff
verimpft worden woran liegt das und wie
stehen sie zu der these mit blick darauf
zwei verschiedene impfstoffen bei den
bei der seine zwei impfungen zu mischen
zum ersten mal auch grundsätzlich das
ist gerade schon gesagt wollen aber auch
auch mir und uns sehr wichtig alle drei
in europa zugelassenen impfstoffe sind
sicher aber vor allen dingen auch
wirksame impfstoffe
das paul-ehrlich-institut hat ja auch
nochmal gestern sehr klar gemacht in
einer stellungnahme dass alle drei
impfstoffe auch der astra zenica
impfstoff eben auch ja das halten was
sie halten sollen nämlich dass sie
wirksam schützen vor der kurve 19
erkrankung und dass niemand der in
studien der der erste und zweite impfung
mit astrazeneca hatte anschließend
behandlungsbedürftig in einem
krankenhaus in der klinik aufgenommen
werden musste im vergleich auch zu denen
die nicht geimpft worden sind also es
bietet schutz und deswegen ist es aus
meiner sicht sehr wichtig dass wenn eine
impfung angeboten wird sie auch
wahrgenommen wird man schützt sich und
man schützt andere und es ist ja auch
ich meine bekommen jeden tag viele
nachfrage viele briefe viele situationen
wo menschen beschreiben warum sie jetzt
eigentlich auch gerne geimpft werden
sollten oder müssten auch wegen
vorerkrankungen wie in ihrer beruflichen
situation das impfangebot zu bekommen
ist ein privileg es ist gerade ziemlich
knapp dieser impfstoff wir priorisieren
deswegen nach bestimmten kriterien aber
wenn das angebot ankommt ist das auch
ein angebot das erst mal in dieser phase
gerade schon ein besonderes ist und
deswegen kann ich eben nur dafür werben
dieses angebot tatsächlich auch
wahrzunehmen
der impfstoff ist empfohlen astra
zyniker für die 18 bis 64 jährigen
deswegen gehen alle länder können jetzt
über gehen in diesen tagen denke ich
wird das bei allen ländern der fall sein
von rio gruppe 1 18 bis 64 jährige auch
in die priorisierung des gruppe 2
das sind weiterhin beschäftigt dem
gesundheitswesen es sind aber auch
polizisten und polizisten etwa die im
einsatz sind sich deswegen in
risikosituationen befinden können was
ansteckungen angeht
es sind menschen mit vorerkrankungen und
wenn wir die impfverordnung jetzt ändern
dann auch im nächsten schritt
erzieherinnen und erzieher
grundschullehrer ein grundschullehrer
das heißt bei den 18 bis 64 jährigen bin
ich sehr sich also es wird nichts weil
ich gestern die frage wird gestellt
denn es bleiben impfstoffdosen liegen es
bleibt nichts liegen es wird angeboten
wenn jemand sagt er möchte das nicht
wird es dem nächsten angeboten mein
eindruck ist dass es hinreichend viele
in deutschland gibt die dieses angebot
auch gerne sich zu schützen er
wahrnehmen werden
letzte frage war ja die frage ob man
wechseln soll zwischen erster und
zweiter punkt den impfstoff das
empfiehlt die ständige impfkommission
ausdrücklich nicht vor allem weil es
dazu keine studiendaten bisher gibt
deswegen werden wir das erste und zweite
in erster zweiter neben mit demselben im
stück mit dem gleichen impfstoff auch
weiterempfehlen und unbedingt vorsehen
das heißt aber nicht dass man zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt wir wissen jetzt zum
beispiel nicht ob man nicht noch eine
booster impfung braucht also eine
verstärkende impfung möglicherweise nach
12 18 24 monaten oder mehr das wird sich
ja noch zeigen dann kann man natürlich
auch mit einem anderen impfstoff geimpft
werden man kann auch zusätzlich später
noch mal geimpft werden wer jetzt eine
impfung bekommt kann natürlich dann wenn
auch andere mengen verfügbar sind und
das angebot breiter ist sich noch einmal
im
lassen das geht übrigens bei allen
anderen impfstoffen auch dass das impfen
an sich das immunsystem damit er dann
auch umgehen kann und das noch mal
verstärkt wird aber jetzt im moment so
wie es auch empfohlen ist erst und zwei
dämpfern mit dem gleichen impfstoff da
sagte umkehrschluss weil sie von den
produkten gesprochen haben dass menschen
die in keiner dieser expliziten perücke
und sind jetzt keine hoffnung machen
können dass sie ja dran kommen der übrig
gebliebenen impfstoffe der begriff übrig
geblieben ist halt aus meiner sicht
nicht der richtige sondern ist neben mir
sehr viele dieses angebot wahr und es
wird wissen sie es gibt jetzt eine
zeitverzögerung am anfang weil die
länder erst mal die infrastruktur
aufbauen mussten und jetzt auch astra
zenica und anderes in die vererzung zu
bringen aber es wird jetzt jeden tag
mehr werden und die gruppe von der ich
gerade gesprochen hat der pensions-
gruppe 27 also technisch aber eben vor
allem diejenigen die besonderes risiko
haben weg für kranken und beruflich
gesundheitswesen polizei sicherheit kita
grundschule
das ist eine sehr sehr große gruppe das
wären einige millionen menschen sein und
dort wird das angebot jetzt gemacht
werden und nachdem es dort gemacht
worden ist kommt die nächste gruppe und
insofern mit jedem stoff der mehr
verfügbar ist und verengt wird kommt die
nächste gruppe früher dran weil in der
logik ist minister rolle die frage warum
so wenig
astrazeneca impfstoff verimpft ob das
leben dort ging explizit auch wenn sie
also ich würde es noch einmal klipp und
klar sagen es ist immens wichtig dass
das was wir jetzt an impfstoffen haben
auch für impfen und dass der impfstoff
gut und sicher ist es ist die botschaft
und gott sei dank machen jetzt viele
ärzte und viele wissenschaftler auch
deutlich dass dieser impfstoff hilft
wirkt und auch gegen schwere
krankheitsverläufe
das müssen wir immer wieder sagen weil
wir sonst in eine diskussion kommen die
schwierig ist die kommunikation an
dieser stelle ist immens wichtig und ich
glaube auch dass wir sehr schnell von
einer priorisierung die nächste kommen
und weiter und ich bin auch dafür wenn
wir dann impfstoff haben und es gibt
leute die geimpft werden möchten dann
müssen wir uns überlegen wie die auch
geimpft werden können
astrazeneca das ist schon eine aufgabe
die auch mal geprüft werden muss also
ich will das nicht ausschließen dass wir
darüber nachdenkt wenn irgendwo in den
priorisierungen auf einmal das angebot
nicht angenommen werden wird es gibt
aber menschen die sagen ich möchte das
aber gerne dass dann die wissenschaft
oder auch die stiko und andere sagen wie
können wir das so auch hinkriegen dass
die damit geimpft werden wolle auch
geimpft werden kann
ich glaube das wird auch nicht
diskussion die wir durchaus auch nochmal
mit den ländern und den bundesminister
gemeinsam daran an irgendwelchen stellen
führen aber jetzt im moment ist die
klare aussage drei impfstoffe die wirken
und helfen und die soll nach eingesetzt
werden minister ohne check auch von
außen konkret die frage von angela
mißlbeck vom ärzte nachrichtendienst ob
impfungen nicht auch regional gesteuert
und priorisiert werden müssten also
zuerst wunsiedel tirschenreuth und ja es
gibt die wünsche auch einige die sagen
gebrachten dort mehr impfstoff auch an
der grenze aber im moment ist der
impfstoff ein knappes gut das wir
einsetzen dass auch in den gesamten
bundesland nach bevölkerung schlüssel
eingesetzt wird und deswegen glaube ich
ist es gut wie wir jetzt dort vorgehen
wir unterstützen die landkreise ja mit
anderen fragen testungen beratung und
vielen anderen dingen deswegen glaube
ich ist das regime wie es jetzt
durchgeführt wird richtig und sinnvoll
und wir werden ja jetzt davon geht
zumindest aus verlässlich um planbar
auch mehr impfstoff kriegen wenn du in
zufügen darf den ersten teil der frage
es wird ja regional gesteuert als wäre
ich wenn in einer region aller ärztinnen
und ärzte geimpft sind oder alle
pflegekräfte
dann wird regional natürlich die nächste
priorisierung gruppe angegangen nämlich
polizistin polizisten oder andere
bereiche des gesundheitswesens
das können wir ja nicht zentral
bundeseinheitlich machen weil dir dafür
ist die demographie die situation die
lage zu unterschiedlich seien die länder
machen das auch so lage angepasst
regional wenn man in einer regionalen
der priorisierung gruppe 1 das angebot
gemacht hat dann kommen natürlich
sozusagen fließender übergang auch die
nächste gruppe dran da wartet man jetzt
nicht bis in jeder region in deutschland
sozusagen situation aber das passiert ja
faktisch auch jeden tag bittet ihre
frage danach links florian ersparen was
konkret unternimmt die bundesregierung
um die produktion
und von schnell und selbsttests
tatsächlich anzukurbeln denn die
erwartungen an diese schnellen selbst
letzten jahr riesig sie könnten game
changer sein aber wenn sie jetzt am
anfang nicht verfügbar sind ist die
erwartung wieder enttäuscht also was
unternehmen sie konkret um die
produktion anzukurbeln
die frage kann ich vielleicht noch mit
dazu bündeln dann von florian kain von
bild konkret wie werden sie
sicherstellen dass die angekündigten
schnell test am ersten märz tatsächlich
verfügbar sind also zu der frage dass es
nicht auch vor allem in den ersten tagen
lokal und situationsbedingt auch zu
engpässen kommen kann weil wenn alle
gleichzeitig an einem bestimmten ort
möglicherweise anspruch dass in anspruch
nehmen wollen kann ich das nicht
ausschließen das würde ich gleich für
verwaltungsmanagement vorneweg sagen was
wir aber wissen von den herstellern vor
allem auch von den groß
volumenherstellern das sind zum teil
große konzerne aber zum teil auch große
mittelständler dass sie viele viele
millionen tests mittlerweile und zwar
nicht 5 millionen er in der
größenordnung von 50 100 und mehr
millionen pro monat
insgesamt produzieren und auch dem
europäischen markt zu führen und wir
gerade bei den schnelltests im moment an
keiner stelle irgendeinen mangel haben
mehr als ausreichend deswegen ist die
frage der produktionsförderung wir haben
ein programm aufgelegt als
bundesregierung es gibt auch einige
anträge und die werden jetzt daneben
auch wenn die unterlagen da sind schnell
beschieden
wir sehen aber wir wollen ja vor allem
auch innovative also innovationen
ich kann ja innovation sein bei der
frage wie der test gemacht wird wie
einfach und anderes mehr auch
entsprechend fördern weil wir sehen dass
bei den schnelltests die
produktionskapazitäten und er sagen die
hersteller ja auch das lässt sich
relativ gut skalieren enorm gewachsen
sind weltweit in den letzten drei vier
monaten und ich deswegen also sehr
zuversichtlich bin dass ich das auch
dann gut einpendeln wird und wie eine
gute verfügbarkeit haben auch mit dem
schritt den wir gehen was die
selbsttests angeht
sehen wir dass an vielen stellen
übrigens auch die durchaus dieselben
hersteller die schnelltests machen doch
mit ihren erfahrungen aus den schnell
schätzt jetzt auch in dem bereich hinein
gehen
bei denjenigen die wirklich auch
belastbare unterlagen eingereicht haben
bisher wir haben übrigens auch einige
die haben wir den antrag gestellt auf
sonder zulassung aber noch keine
unterlagen eingereicht wir können
natürlich nur da prüfen wo die
unterlagen auch eingereicht sind sind
das auch viele große hersteller bei
denen wir stand heute davon ausgehen
dass dann auch nicht auch da nicht
gleich am ersten tag nach zulassung aber
dann doch relativ schnell auch die
kapazitäten skaliert werden können
hochgefahren werden können und wir sind
mit diesen herstellern in verhandlungen
auch über rahmenverträge wie wir sie bei
den schnelltest auch haben um eben eine
gewisse menge auf jeden fall für den
deutschen markt zu sichern
kurzer zusatz es gibt eine studie die
besagt dass man sich dreimal die woche
pro woche testen müsste um für 90%
sozusagen ihr in dieser pandemie eine
stop zu erwirken ist auch das
realistisch dass in relativ kurzer zeit
jeder bundesbürger sich was dreimal die
woche testen könnte ja das ist natürlich
schon eine große größenordnung jeder
bundesbürger dreimal die woche
ich weiß auch nicht dass ich am ende
frage der bereitschaft keine
verpflichtungen sich testen zu lassen
ist ein angebot
die erfahrungen die wir sehen in anderen
bereichen ist auch in anderen drohe bei
den lehrerinnen und lehrern an die oder
bayern hat ja im übrigen fällt mir
gerade ein auch die erfahrung durchaus
mit einem test angebot für alle ja schon
in den letzten wochen schon gemacht
vielleicht auch zwei sind noch zu sagen
wie das angenommen wird weil 100 prozent
in dem es erfahrungsgemäß nicht an eine
große zahl an dass neben einigen auch
sehr regelmäßig an aber sie müssen ja
sehen die testprozedur an sich ist ja
keine angenehme bei den schnelltest so
dass das eben unterschiedlich
unterschiedliche bereitschaft geben wird
also wenn jeder jeden tag das macht dann
wird es ohne zweifel engpässe geben das
kann ich sicher sagen aber das ist denke
ich nicht das was zu erwarten ist kann
nur sagen das thema testen war bei uns
ja schon von anfang an ein sehr
zentrales jedermann test das war damals
ja auch ein thema des
im rest der republik war umstritten war
ich glaube es ist wichtig und richtig
gewesen den bürgerinnen und bürger ein
großes angebot an testmöglichkeiten zu
machen das wird es auch jetzt sein weil
das testen auch ein teil einer
gesamtstrategie für die zukunft sein
wird und deswegen tun wir gut daran wenn
wir möglichst breites anbieten wir
werden das jetzt auch bei den schulen
wenn die selbst auch zur verfügung
stehen mit einsätzen bei den
kindergärten und ich denke je mehr wir
testen können desto besser ist es und
das muss auch das ziel sein und deswegen
wollen wir länder auch dann gemeinsam
mit dem bund sehen wie funktioniert das
alles wo kann getestet werden welche
bereiche sind dabei apotheken und all
die dinge und wie wird es dann konkret
aus gesteuert in dem zusammenhang jetzt
noch zwei fragen von außen rein dann
sind wir im grunde schon am ende der
zeit zwei fragen aus dem saal habe ich
andere dotiert die kollegin hinten und
sie hat sich sehr früh gemeldet
ansonsten muss ich sowohl die kollegen
außen als auch in saal um verständnis
bitten dass nicht alle fragen in unserem
zeitrahmen unterkommen
aber es wird nicht die letzte
pressekonferenz in diesem format seien
zu den tests jetzt angeschlossen von der
pharmazeutischen zeitung vor kurzem die
tests gleich zu anfang gegen eine
geringe eigenbeteiligung von etwa 1 euro
in apotheken discountern und
einzelhandel abgegeben werden oder ob
diese günstige abgabe erst geplant ist
wenn die tests einige zeit auf dem markt
sind und frau mißlbeck vom ärzte
nachrichten dienstag
entschuldigung das bezieht sich auch was
anderes aber es gab die frage von der
abt von apotheke adhoc holstein warum
keine apothekenpflicht bei laien tests
bei beratung konkrete anwendung sicher
zu stellen
wie werden die ergebnisse erfasst zum
beispiel über eine app also bei den
selbsttests oder leinen tests ist sehr
wichtig auch teil des
zulassungsprozesses dass es eine
packungsbeilage eine erklärung dabei
gibt wie man den test eben als laie
anwendet ist hat die voraussetzungen so
genau das worüber wir sozusagen reden
das eine ist die qualität aber eben auch
dass nachgewiesen sein muss dass der
nicht geschulte reihe
diesen test auch sicher durchführen kann
und dass es eben auch entsprechende
beilagen informationen dann zu dem test
gibt das muss aus unserer sicht
gewährleistet sein
wir wollen aber gleichzeitig eben eine
breite verfügbarkeit gewährleisten und
eine breite verfügbarkeit übrigens im
zweifel auch eine günstigere
verfügbarkeit ergibt sich eben wenn es
dann auch tatsächlich in allen bereichen
des handels verfügbar sein werden diese
tests ich weiß auch von discountern und
drogeriemärkten anderen die sich
natürlich mit der frage beschäftigen
wenn die tests zugelassen sind wie sie
sie dann auch in ihr sortiment einführen
können sie sollen einfach breit und
idealerweise natürlich auch möglichst
günstig dann verfügbar sein
das bringt mich zur ersten frage die
veränderung der test verordnung wird im
ersten schritt jetzt die schnelltests ab
märz beinhalten konkret die veränderung
selbst tests werden wir noch in der
bundesregierung auch im kreis zwischen
verschiedenen ressorts einfach
miteinander auch darauf schauen müssen
wie sich das entwickelt ich kann ihnen
jetzt noch nicht sagen zum beispiel wie
der preis das preisniveau sein wird es
macht ja für die frage ob wir sozusagen
finanziell mit einsteigen im rahmen
einer test verordnung ein unterschied ob
das jetzt sind die zwei euro kosten im
markt oder zehn euro bei zehn euro ist
offenkundig ein größerer bedarf ist auch
kostengünstig zu machen als wenn der
test nachher für zwei euro relativ
niedrigschwellig verfügbar ist und das
lässt sich eben erst sehen dann auch
nach den ersten zwei drei wochen
erfahrungen im übrigen auch die
verfügbarkeit wird deine frage sein wie
sehr wie schnell sind die selbsttests
auch verfügbar
weil wenn wir sie zum bestandteil
unserer bundes test verordnung machen
brauchen sie immer per se auch schon
eine hohe verfügbarkeit um danach es
auch sicherzustellen was da passiert ist
das aber die länder sie müssen sehen die
tat strategien für kitas und schulen
werden ja von den ländern gemacht und
umgesetzt und dort sind ja viele länder
tatsächlich jetzt schon dabei sofort
nach zulassung solcher selbsttests dann
auch in ihre kita und schule test
strategien einzubauen so weil ich eben
schon halb anmoderiert von frau
mittelberg weg die frage von
den nachrichtendienst die war die bezog
sich auf dokumentation von impfungen und
zwar der hinweis reisemediziner
kritisieren dass eine sichere und
schnellere dokumentation der impfung
empfiehlt etwa ein fälschungssicherer
stempel für den impfpass und man nicht
auf eine digitale lösung der eu warten
könne
wie ist der stand der vorbereitung
handlung diesbezüglich tja das ist einer
der punkte der impf nach weiß wo ich mir
immer denkt hätten wir schon das
digitale gelöst wäre es natürlich an
dieser stelle leicht hat der digitale
impfpass das ist jetzt seit drei vier
jahren planung wird zum ersten ersten
2022 beginnen als teil der
elektronischen patientenakte
wir wollen aber gerne darüber also wir
reden gerade darüber ob wir eine
vorübergehende lösung eine
zwischenlösung auf dem weg zum digitalen
im spaß für konkret diese impfung auch
möglich machen digital im rahmen auch
der initiative der europäischen union es
geht ja auch darum dass die sozusagen
diese nationale lösung dann mit
schnittstellen kompatibel sind dafür hat
die europäische union ende januar eben
schnittstellen und bestimmte parameter
definiert und darüber beraten wir jetzt
das papier den papier nachweis den
klassischen für eine erfolgte impfung
weder im impfbuch oder durch eine
bescheinigung die sind eben die
klassischen varianten die jetzt auch so
bleiben wie sie wie sie sind und
weitergeführt werden bitte rundfunk
ersparen wann genau dritten diese neue
im priorisierung wanderte inkrafttreten
vor dreier zum beispiel in rheine falls
gesagt vor ostern noch den
grundschullehrerinnen und lehrern und
ihren kita kräften ein info angebot
machen zu wollen dann also wenn wir das
jetzt mit den kolleginnen und kollegen
in den ländern sprechen jetzt sehr
zeitnah und dort was sich ja abzeichnet
ein relativ großer konsens ist dann
werden wir die verordnung zügig ändern
können
und dann müssen die länder da sind wir
wieder bei der frage von gerade also der
abfolge dann wenn sichergestellt ist
dass die priorisierung gruppe 1
die pflegekräfte altenpflege intensiv
medizin die ärztin und ärzte die die
jenigen den impfzentren arbeiten also
der bereich der dort zuerst höchste
priorität hat wenn dort allein angebot
bekommen haben dann kann ich eben in die
gruppe 2 übergehen und dann kann man
auch beginnen wenn sie denn dann nach
änderung der impfung dort sind die
erzieherinnen erzieher die
grundschullehrern grundschullehrer zu
impfen
also wenn der konsens jetzt da ist
werden wir die rechtliche grundlage
schnell dann schaffen wie gesagt für
mich ist auch wichtig das ist fachlich
hergeleitet ist nämlich darüber dass
eben in diesen berufs kontext
berufsalltag hygiene abstand
infektionsrisiken vermindern nicht so
möglich ist als in vielen anderen
schulformen man deswegen eben diesen weg
dann auch begründet gehen kann und dann
müssen die länder nach ihrem im
fortschritt im land entscheiden wann sie
eben in den nächsten wochen jeweils
damit beginnen und beginnen können weil
die vorherige prioritäre gruppe schon
geimpft ist oder ins angebot bekommen wo
jetzt die beiden kolleginnen hier werden
sich auch sehr früh gemeldet bitte meine
frage richtet sich an die beiden herren
minister
wie gehen sie eigentlich mit menschen um
die grundsätzlich geimpft werden wollen
aber den impfstoff astrazeneca ablehnen
verwirken die ihr recht auf ein schnelle
impfungen müssen die sich ganz hinten
anstellen wenn erst einmal alle
durchgeimpft sind die dran sind mit
einem erst aufrufen wie handhaben sie
das also grundsätzlich ist vorgesehen
dass wir sein angebot nicht
also man kann entscheidet man sich
impfen lassen würde da nicht aber wer
jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt nicht will mit
dem angebotenen impfstoff der ist dann
halt jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt auch kann
nicht geimpft werden zu diesem zeitpunkt
das heißt nicht zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt wenn man natürlich in einer
nach in der woche sagt man ist jetzt
doch bereit diesen impfstoff zu nehmen
dann denke ich wird das problemlos
möglich sein sich dann wieder auch an zu
melden und einen termin geben zu lassen
aber sie müssen ja einsehen warum wir
das auch so machen wir haben jetzt zwei
impfstoffe den ein bis jetzt nur in sehr
geringen mengen moderner die im auch für
über 80 jährige für die älteren
empfohlen sind das ist die gruppe mit
dem höchsten risiko jeder zweite
todesfall in deutschland ist bei über 80
jährigen zu beklagen und deswegen finde
ich es sehr wichtig dass wir die
situation die wir jetzt haben zwei
impfstoffe für über acht auch für über
80 jährige zugelassen für alle
altersgruppen und einen impfstoff nicht
zugelassen empfohlen sowie ständige
impfkommission und ein impfstoff 18 bis
empfohlen für 18 bis 64 das gibt uns die
möglichkeit bei beiden gruppen schneller
zu sein
bei den über 80 jährigen und bei den 18
bis 64 jährigen in den risiko können
schneller diejenigen schützen die zuerst
geschützt werden sollten auch nach den
empfehlungen das funktioniert aber nur
wenn man es dann eben auch so macht das
die angebote entsprechend gemacht werden
wir haben ja keine impfpflicht das heißt
wir haben die impfung auf freiwilliger
basis insofern ist es jetzt ein angebot
mit einem verknappten gut weil der
impfstoff ja nicht so da ist wie wäre es
eigentlich bräuchten insofern bin ich
der meinung dass wir jetzt tatsächlich
kein wunschkonzert haben über die frage
welcher impfstoff zur verfügung steht
ich habe aber vorher auch deutlich
gemacht ich will nicht ausschließen dass
man überlegen müssen hat irgendeinem
zeitpunkt dass die menschen auch die
jetzt sagen würde gern geimpft werden
auch mit astrazeneca es geht jetzt im
wesentlichen und diesen impfstoff auch
ein angebot kriegen wir müssen da schon
dran bleiben im wahrsten sinn des wortes
das ist eine entwicklung und für mich
kein statisches system und das ist auch
das was wir glaube ich wollen dass wir
da immer genau darauf schauen und auch
diese entwicklung nachvollziehen
und dann brauchen wir in den ländern
natürlich auch gewisse zeit in der
vorbereitung in der umstellung deswegen
ist es immer gut wenn wir da eingebunden
sind und wenn auch die vorlaufzeit immer
richtig ist
sabine am orde von der taz herr spahn
ich habe eine frage noch mal zu den
finanzwerten und zwar ist ja auch dank
herr laschet sind die zahlen ja wieder
ziemlich in einer diskussion
es gibt die 50 die 35er wieder thema
gesagt sehen wir eine coole zahl das was
ähnliches hört man auch aus dem
kanzleramt
mit blick auf lockerung welt
zahl finden sie denn da die richtige wir
hatten ja diese frage dieses starke
fokussieren auf eine zahl vor etwa einem
jahr schon mal da haben alle auf den er
wert geschaut und wir haben damals schon
immer darauf hingewiesen auch herr
professor wieder und ich dass man immer
den gesamtkontext sehen muss und nicht
nur eine zahl
und deswegen finde ich es wichtig das
infektionsschutzgesetz nennt vor allem
die 50 und die 35 institute pro 100000
den letzten sieben tagen ja auch nicht
blickt der verschärfung von maßnahmen
und der dynamik und ich finde es auch
richtig dass wir zahlen definieren auch
um sozusagen schritte nachvollziehbar
daraus abzuleiten
aber es ist doch genauso wichtig eben
auch die anderen parameter und in den
blick zu nehmen wie ist es gerade ist
wie ist er also wie ist die ansteckung
sind stecken steckt einer gerade zwei
weitere an oder steckt einer weniger als
einen weiteren an macht für die frage ob
die in standby 40 irgendwie handelbarer
ist oder nicht ein riesenunterschied
geht es gerade so oder geht's gut so
deswegen ist ja sozusagen die die zahl
an sich nicht alleine ausreichend ich
weiß dass das bedürfnis eine zahl eine
maßzahl zu haben und danach alles
auszurichten sehr sehr groß ist das habe
ich im zweifel auch weil das sozusagen
ein zielmarkt gesetzt auf die man
hinarbeiten kann aber den gefallen tut
uns das infektionsgeschehen nicht und
die dynamische lage einfach nicht und
deswegen muss man immer schon auch mehr
betrachten 1 ist aber ohne zweifel
richtig
es muss möglichst weit runter um besser
kontrollierbar zu sein um so niedriger
desto besser in der nachverfolgbarkeit
desto besser für das gesundheitssystem
in der belastung desto besser ein in
vielerlei hinsicht umso weiter wir das
vermeiden dass andere angesteckt werden
desto besser nochmal eine nachfrage auch
wenn die sache ist so nur eine zahl von
mir und sein aber wenn wir mal auf diese
eine zahl
angemessener größe mit blick auf die
lockerungen beginnen ja schon also wir
haben ja in den ersten bundesländern
bereits seit dieser woche beginnend kita
und schule unter bestimmten pandemie
jene bedingungen wir haben ab montag in
weiteren ländern den beginn und und
danach an weiteren wir haben dass die
frage der friseure am ersten märz es
werden ja die ersten schritte gegangen
weil eben das infektionsgeschehen
eingeschätzt worden ist gemeinsam so
dass das jetzt erste mögliche schritte
sind und dass wir dann auch schauen was
folgt aus diesen schritten für das
infektionsgeschehen also schule und kita
zu schließen das habe ich immer gesagt
ist eine der letzten maßnahmen weil es
mit wahnsinnig viel härte wirklich ist
für die eltern wie für die kinder das
ist eine echt schwere zeit in den
letzten wochen und eine maßnahme die ja
niemandem leicht fällt und gleichzeitig
ist es so dass wenn sie sie wieder
öffnen
das millionenfache mobilität jeden tag
nach sich zieht das ist einer der
bereiche der am meisten sozusagen
bewegung mit sich bringt einfach
zwischen menschen und deswegen müssen
wir das jetzt gemeinsam an so ist ja
auch vereinbart und sehr genau anschauen
aber es ist jetzt nicht so als wenn mit
den gesunkenen infektionszahlen jetzt
nicht auch die ersten schritte gegangen
würden wir kolleginnen liebe kollegen
noch einmal bitte um verständnis dass
nicht alle fragen einige sind noch offen
beantwortet werden können aber ich denke
wir sehen uns wieder politik wenn man
ist das sparen danke für die reise aus
münchen wieder vielen dank